hey guys it's Quinn's ideas here and
it's time for another quick video
discussion on the dune saga I realized
that I say a bunch on this channel that
Paul Atreides should not be viewed as
the hero of the saga and I've given
specific reasons on why I believe this
is the case throughout several of my
videos but I've never done a dedicated
video addressing it and since I often
see questions and contingents regarding
this idea I thought I would respond and
elaborate here at this point after
rereading the dune saw the several times
I'm pretty convinced that this is the
way that Frank Herbert intended the
character to be viewed within the
context of the whole series as always if
you're interested in learning more about
the dune series please subscribe and
definitely check out the dune playlist
on the front of this channel to start
off we have to take a look at what Frank
Herbert had to say about his own series
to quote Herbert I wrote the dune saga
because I had this idea that charismatic
leaders ought to come with the warning
label maybe dangerous to your health
Herbert is definitely referring to his
character Paul Atreides in the book dune
Paul is able to become leader of the
Freeman and unseat the Emperor of the
known universe upon first look dune
appears to follow the classic hero's
journey
archetype but by examining the book
further and by diving into the further
books in the series the truth becomes
clearer in the subtext of dune hidden
beneath the main plot involving the rear
section of House Atreides is something
far darker than most people who are
casually aware of the dune series may
realize to understand this we must first
take a look at the way in which Paul
Atreides is able to rise amongst the
Fremen
and eventually become their Messiah
in other videos we've discussed the been
a Jesuit sisterhood and their
involvement with the religious seating
of the planet Arrakis by use of their
mission ara protect Eva the sisterhood
had the goal of creating a super being
through careful manipulation of
bloodlines once they had achieved that
they would use this being who would be a
male possessing of all their powers and
more to manipulate the citizens of the
universe and shape the destiny of
mankind as they saw fit to make it
easier for the universe to accept their
being who they would call the quiz
that's had Iraq they set up false
prophecies on countless planets
throughout the empire prophecies which
would herald the coming of this being
the oppressed Freeman of the planet
Arrakis who had once been the son Sunni
Wanderers would have been prime
candidates for myth seeding if the
Sisterhood's plan had gone correctly
then they would have been able to wield
the strength of a super being but The
Sisterhood was never able to control
Paul once Paul is in the deep deserts of
Arrakis his powers are awakened by the
spice his prescient
eye begins to open and he starts to see
the full design of the Bene Jesuit plan
he also sees the path that will avenge
his father and restore the name of
tradies but it comes at a great cost
he knew the Fremen would call him God
Lisa and alga Eve the voice from the
outer world born of a bene Jesuit mother
as the prophecy foretold fanatics would
be created and the jihad of purification
would spread throughout the universe in
his name like a virus oppressing
countless worlds and costing the lives
of 60 billion humans the other path held
long patches of grey obscurity except
for peaks of violence he had seen a
warrior religion there a fire spreading
across the universe with the Atreides
green and black banner waving at the
head of fanatic legions drunk on spiced
liqueur guarentee Halleck and a few
others of his father's men a pitiful few
were among them all marked by the hawk
symbol from the shrine of his father's
skull
now let's be clear Paul did not want the
jihad to happen he doesn't fully
understand the visions and time itself
is not what it appears to be as later
the second points out in Children of
Dune the future forks in many potential
directions depending on what decisions
we make
Paul's prescient power however allows
him to see the future results of his
actions because of this he is able to
direct the path to become the fulcrum by
which fate turns upon throughout the
book Paul is haunted by visions of the
jihad he searches for a way to prevent
it but by then it has already gone too
far and in no path can he unsee it
surely I cannot choose that way he
thought but he saw it again in his
mind's eye the shrine of his father
skull and the violence with the green
and black banner waving in its midst
in the end Paul unseats the emperor and
restores the name of tradies but
something terrible has been set in
motion and in truth terrible things have
already been done on Arrakis the Fremen
had been manipulated into following a
man who allowed them to believe he was
God when he was not over the course of
the next 12 years the Fremen culture
withers and grades many of those who
follow Paul have now turned against him
the people of the Imperium begged for a
constitution but Paul rejects any
Constitution nothing may override his
power he allows nothing to limit his
Imperial will at this time all but a
fraction of the human universe existed
under Paul's rule Paul clings to his
empire out of fear of what is to come
hoping to save himself he knows that he
must act but doesn't even though he is
the only one who can I know this is
cliche but I really do have to quote
spider-man here with great power comes
great responsibility
Paul had seen the jihad too late and
failed to prevent the death of billions
of innocence but the jihad was a mere
fraction of what was to come
he remembered his earliest visions of
the jihad to be the terror and revulsion
he'd experienced now of course he knew
visions of greater terrors yet lived
with the real violence he had seen his
Freeman charged with mystical strength
sweep all before them in the religious
war the jihad gained a new perspective
it was finite of course a brief spasm
when measured against eternity but
beyond lay horrors to overshadow
anything in the past Paul knew that he
could stop it
he knew that he actually had a chance to
be the hero that he never really was to
save humanity from the horror that lay
in the darkness beyond he saw Crowley
sack the mythic battle at the end of
time but was unwilling to pay the
ultimate price to stop it he thought of
the jihad of the gene mingling across
parsecs and the vision which told him
how he might end it should he pay the
price all the hatefulness would
evaporate dying as fires die umber by
umber but oh the terrifying price I
never wanted to be a god he thought I
wanted only to disappear like a jewel of
trace do caught by the morning I wanted
to escape the Angels and the damned
alone as though by an oversight
the cost of what he must do in order to
save humanity haunts Paul throughout the
second book but ultimately he makes his
decision he puts himself before humanity
pushing the task of fixing the damage he
had done and preventing the ultimate
extinction of humankind on to his son
late to the second who would undergo
3,500 years of agony in his father's
place Paul saw the horrors of the golden
path which would ensure human survival
he saw the cruelty of it and he saw
Crowley's ech he weighed them against
each other but was unable to make the
decision unable to lock humankind into
the correct path Paul son Leto calls him
out on this when they finally meet at
the end of the book children of doom it
is sad that you were never really
Freeman later said we Freeman know how
to Commission the aretha our judges can
choose between evils it has always been
that way for us the curious thing about
Children of Dune is that late to the
second inherits the sins of his father
and he knows that it is up to him to do
what his father failed to do but in
order to do this he must move beyond his
humanity and become a true God and
prepare mankind for what is to come
though he knew he would never be thanked
for it theoretically it did not have to
be Leto who took on this burden his twin
sister Janina could have also taken his
place but he chose to spare her that
agony
Paul is the hero of the book dune in the
sense that he is the hero of his own arc
he gained her fins for his house and
becomes Emperor but he is not the hero
of the dune saga when the series as a
whole is considered Paul is not only
incapable of fixing the mess he made
once he sees a bigger mess in the future
that only he can stop he doesn't really
try he just gives up I know this is
quite the deflating resolution after the
epic ending of the first book and I
assure you this is intentional Frank
Herbert wants the reader to see the fal
ability of Paul to see that he is just a
man and always was regardless of what
powers he seems to possess it all goes
back to the key theme of dune which I
discussed in my video titled what's the
point of doom don't blindly follow
behind leaders always question alright
guys so this concisely as I can put it
is the reason why I think that Paul is
not meant to be viewed as the hero of
the day saga thank you guys so much for
watching please subscribe for more dnews
and as always with the new denis
villeneuve dude movie come
this year's starting team with a child
May we will be seeing more and more dune
movie news as the months go on and on
and I will be covering it all here on
this channel so please make sure you
like and subscribe let's hope that Paul
Atreides is portrayed accurately on the
big screen thank you guys so much for
watching
[Music]
special shout-out to my top patrons
Trini girl
Joseph Rosner Milton Christopher Appling
Richard Hess Deus Technica Giuliana
aaliyan the Collier report Paula
Zack glaze our Matthew Snyder Jim nimeth
Alex Butler and Frederick Northland
[Music]